hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled reference materials an
introduction to quality grade and an
overview on the different types of food
and beverages
i'm susie valdez of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
milliporesigma so let's get started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's
speaker dr matias knowledge a product
manager for reference materials at
milliport sigma
potease has worked at military stigma
since 2016 with a special focus on
reference materials
for food and beverage tasting for a
complete biography
i'm doctor knowledge please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen dr knowles you
may now begin
your presentation welcome sir
thank you very much i'm very pleased to
have the opportunity
to talk today about reference materials
in food and beverage testing
before i start i have to point out that
the life science business
of merck kgaa darmstadt germany
operates as milipor sigma in the u.s and
canada
the presentation consists of a technical
part
introducing you to some general terms
and definitions about reference
materials
and an introduction about the different
quality grades and certification methods
then i will show you our range of
reference materials
suitable for fnp testing and explain you
how you can find the products
and finally i am going to show you some
highlight product groups a bit more in
detail
so let me start with a very basic
question
what does testing actually mean
well testing in the essence is the
comparison of an unknown sample with
something known
and that something known is what we
refer to as the reference material
this means that the quality of your
reference materials
is directly affecting the quality of
your analytical result
as you can see here there are many
aspects of a product that can be tested
testing can be qualitative or
quantitative
qualitative tests typically confirm the
identification of an analyte or its
presence or absence in a sample
quantitative tests for example determine
the actual amount of an analyte in a
sample
or the potency of a drug
tests can focus either on the material
itself
for example its identity chromatographic
purity
content as mass percentage or physical
properties like melting point or
viscosity
other tests focus on the impurities
present in a material
which can be water residual solvents
organic or inorganic impurities
each of these different aspects of
testing require a specific reference
material
reference materials can be used in
different formats in the testing
laboratory
depending on product availability and
method requirements
the three formats for reference
materials are a need form
usually as a powder or liquid in
solution
or in matrix neat reference materials
are typically available in a screw top
vial
they can be used to make stock or
working solutions
often weighed and prepared daily or
weekly
the advantage of using neat reference
materials
is the big flexibility for different
applications
with larger material amount available
also many chemicals are more stable in
powder form
on the other hand there is an additional
handling step required by the end user
which can bear challenges especially if
the material is hygroscopic
viscose or toxic depending on the skills
there can thus be a greater weak to weak
variability
of the resulting working solution
reference materials in solution with
certified concentration and stability
will avoid these problems these are very
convenient to use and save a lot of
preparation time
especially for calibration mixtures
on the other hand you rely on the
availability of a solution mix
suitable for your need and have less
flexibility
matrix reference materials provide the
analytes in a matrix similar to the
sample analyzed
these are used to develop and validate
test methods
and to correct bias from the sample
preparation step
having certified matrix materials
commercially available
saves the time and effort to produce
in-house matrix materials
for example by spiking with an analyte
but the number of available matrix
materials is limited
so often there is no suitable product
available
also the analytes are often less stable
in a matrix
limiting the shelf life of these
products
i would like to introduce some metrology
terms now
a measurement is considered to be true
if the mean of all individual
measurements are close to the true value
as shown in the example on the left side
however the results here are widespread
meaning that the measurement is not
precise
and has a high uncertainty
the example on the right hand side shows
a precise test
with all individual results being close
together
however there is a bias in all these
measurements
so as a consequence this result is not
accurate
for analytical results in general and
reference materials in particular
we are aiming for accurate values
meaning that they are precise
so the reference materials should only
have a small uncertainty contribution to
the measurement
and also the value should reflect the
true value
this can be achieved by assuring
traceability
metrological traceability is an
important concept in the world of
reference materials
it means that measurements can be
meaningfully compared
across different places at different
times
by different people and using different
equipment
the measurement result must hereby be
related to a reference
through a documented and unbroken chain
of calibrations
tracing back to the si unit of
measurement
the international system of units or s-i
defines the seven units of measure as
the basic set
from which all other si units can be
derived
the two most common si units of measure
for traceability of reference materials
are kilogram and mole which we use in
our reference material certification
methods
and certificates of analysis
now with this basic metrological concept
in mind
let's take a look at the different types
of reference materials
as this hierarchy pyramid shows the
level of certification
and traceability requirements increases
the higher you climb up in the pyramid
at the top level we find the primary
standards
the primary measurement standards are
produced by national metrology
institutes like nist in the us or jrc in
europe
these authorized bodies are recognized
by their national governments
as the source of truth considered to
provide the highest level of accuracy
and traceability
in a reference standard
in the pharmaceutical world you have
primary compendium standards
produced by the pharmacopeias like usp
in the u.s
or the european pharmacopoeia
while not necessarily a government
entity
these pharmacopoeias work closely with
government agencies
and are legally recognized in many
countries
as providing the highest level of
accurate and traceable reference
standards for use in pharmaceutical
monograph testing
where national governments give
standardization to the top level
specific iso requirements provide
standardization for the next two levels
certified reference material and
reference material
these iso requirements include 17034
and 17025 as well as guide 31.
reference material producers must meet
these iso requirements
to manufacture crms or rms
within iso crms are considered to
provide the highest level of accuracy
uncertainty and traceability to an si
unit of measurement
rms fall one level lower as they are
manufactured and tested
to a level less demanding for both of
these quality grades
certificates of analysis must be
provided
and the information contained within is
defined by iso
also note that while reference materials
is a quality grade
it can also be used as a general term to
encompass
all quality grades within the pyramid
the quality requirements for the last
two levels
are defined by each individual vendor
rather than by a national government or
by iso
for the analytical standard grade
manufactured by our company
the product is manufactured within the
general iso 9001 quality
system requirements not specific to just
reference materials
a certificate of analysis is provided
with an analytical standard grade
reference material
it contains information such as product
identity
purity and an expiration date
generally the level of certification
varies from vendor to vendor
the lowest level is the research grade
or research chemical
these may be well characterized but are
not designed for the use as reference
materials
and not considered analytical products
let's take a deeper look at the
differences among a crm
rm and the analytical standards grade
there are four quality attributes
required for the property value of a crm
stability homogeneity across the lot
uncertainty and traceability to the si
unit of measurement and to an nmi
primary measurement standard if
available
the rm quality requirements include just
the stability and homogeneity attributes
for the property value
but no traceability or uncertainty is
required
for isoguide 31 all information and data
on crm or
rm quality attributes for the property
value
must be included in the certificate of
analysis
for an analytical standard there is no
property value
since the manufacturing and testing of
the reference standard
is not performed according to iso
requirements
specific to reference materials
in the absence of a property value the
focus is on the material itself
is the material sufficiently pure stable
and homogeneous
is the material fit for its intended use
since the c of a for analytical
standards crates
are not aligned to reference material
specific iso or compendial requirements
the information provided in them will
vary from vendor to vendor
iso quality requirements direct the
manufacture
testing and documentation of crms and
rms
iso 17034 accreditation
means that an official body recognizes
the producer's capability
to manufacture crms
an iso 17025 accreditation
means that the laboratory is officially
recognized to be competent in analytical
testing
the accreditation documents provide
guidance on how to manufacture a crm
but only if a company has been
successfully audited by an official
accreditation body
it is authorized to manufacture crms
in addition the isoguide 31 is intended
to help producers
to prepare clear and concise
documentation
to accompany a reference standard such
as the certificate of analysis
note that our company globally has four
different
sites holding an iso 17025
and iso 17034 double accreditation
to manufacture certified reference
materials
iso 17025 accreditation is also relevant
for testing labs
one important note here for accredited
testing labs
the use of a crm grade is mandatory
if commercially available
the iso and pharma worlds have different
definitions of traceability
compendial and pharmaceutical regulatory
guidelines
do not require traceability to the si
units
but to a primary compendial standard
as crms merck secondary standards have
both types of traceability
thus providing greater accuracy for
pharma monograph testing applications
and with that we will look how all these
requirements translate to the content of
a certificate
here is what informations you find on a
cfa of a certified reference material
obviously there has to be a certified
value
this can be the concentration for a
solution crm
or a mass fraction for a neat crm
the value has to be reported with an
uncertainty
which is taking all the contribution
factors into account
including stability and homogeneity of
the material
there needs to be a statement about the
traceability
mentioning the primary material tested
against
which for example can be an east srm
the certificate should provide
information about how the stability and
homogeneity of the material has been
determined
then the certificate would always state
an expiry date
the certified value is guaranteed for
the duration of the shelf life within
the given uncertainty
this slide gives an overview of the
different certificates of analysis
for the different quality grades
it is quite apparent that as the level
of certification increases
the amount of information required on
the certificate increases as well
for more information please refer to our
new
rm quality webpage which you can find on
sigmaaldridge.com
qualitygrades crm
after introducing the different types of
reference materials and formats
i'd now like to discuss how materials
are certified
with focus on organic chemical compounds
here are some of the best practices for
certification of a reference standard
it's important that the material is well
characterized for both
identity and purity
the best approach for identity is clear
identification by techniques
such as nmr and mass spectrometry
purity or potency does not include just
chromatographic purity alone
but also residual solvents water and
trace in organics
from the manufacturing or purification
process
all are required to obtain a complete
picture
of chromatographic and
non-chromatographic impurities in the
material
mass balance uses multiple techniques to
determine
identity purity and all trace impurities
whereas other approaches such as
quantitative nmr
and titration primarily we use one
technique
all approaches are useful for
determination of purity or potency
we are focusing on mass balance
quantitative
nmr and isotope dilution mass
spectrometry
for organic molecules we'll now take a
closer look at
quantitative nmr and mass balance
concept of qnmr involves a high
precision weighing step
of an internal standard and the sample
of interest
after weighing both of these components
into the same vial
a deuterated solvent is added and both
substances are dissolved
because only the ratio of analyte and
internal standard is relevant for the
calculation
the exact concentration of the solution
is not important
after the nmr measurement selected
isolated signals of the sample
and the internal standard are compared
which allows for the calculation of the
mass fraction
with a very high precision
traceability is achieved by using for
example a material from nist
or an east srm traceable internal
standard
qnmr is a primary ratio method
and impurities do not affect the result
after a comprehensive number of tests
from content determination and
homogeneity to stability
the crm is issued in accordance to the
iso 17034
17025 double accreditation
with a certificate provided according to
isoguide 31.
including the components that we have
been discussed previously
like traceability statement expiration
date
certified value expanded uncertainties
as well as the required signatures and
stamps from the accreditation body
now let's take a look at the mass
balance approach
like qnmr the mass balance approach
assigns purity content
which represents the true amount of the
material by weight
here we use a comprehensive panel of
tests
to get a 360 degree view of the molecule
mass balance is not a simple assay to a
similar standard
we perform a full characterization of
the molecule
determining the identity by multiple
methods
and the purity by multiple methods
we perform two to three chromatographic
purity tests
with different columns and detectors
like lc and gc
to ensure we are detecting all
impurities
for an accurate determination of the
mass fraction
no potential impurities can be ignored
so beside the chromatographic purity
the water content residue solvents and
inorganic impurities are measured
each technique includes its own
validated method for carrying out one
part of the full characterization
the formula below shows how all the
results from the different testing
techniques
are taken together to generate the
purity factor for assigning the content
or potency value
as mentioned previously traceability is
an important quality requirement for a
certified reference material
traceability for mass balance is
achieved through each of the individual
component tests
mass measurement in each component test
is traceable through balanced
calibrations to an si
unit of mass in this case the kilogram
other components are traceable through
instrument calibrations and system
suitability tests
using higher order standards
on this slide we have mass balance
certification examples
on a variety of natural product need
materials
many of these compounds are difficult to
isolate
purify and stabilize
as you can see chromatographic purity
alone
is not adequate to assign a total
content
in the case of catechin 3 gallate the
material has residual solvent and water
as well as trace inorganic content
some of it as hydrate and some from the
process of isolation and purification
these residual impurities must be
quantified
and accounted for in use of the material
even though these would not be seen by
hplc or gc
for laboratories preparing their own
in-house working standards
significant error may be introduced in
quantitative uses of the reference
material
without full characterization of the
neat material
so this concludes the technical part of
my presentation
let's now look at the reference
materials for food and beverage testing
food testing is clearly on the rise and
projected to grow
at an average annual growth rate of more
than six percent in the coming years
so who are the players in food testing
and what factors are driving food
testing
well there's a lot of media coverage of
food scandals
incident of food fraud mislabeling or
adulteration
academic research groups are
contributing in discovering such
incidents consumer awareness of food
safety issues are leading to political
pressure
and therefore to the establishment of
new regulations
and a stricter enforcement by
international bodies
like iso or efsa and national
authorities like the fda
the food industry itself also has a big
interest to avoid food scandals
to avoid reputation damage other factors
are emerging contaminants for example
due to climate change
new food trends like insects or cultured
meat
and new increasingly sensitive
analytical techniques
all these factors drive an increase in
food testing
and as we learned in the first slide
reliable test results
require reliable reference materials
our portfolio comprises more than 20 000
certified reference materials and
analytical standards
but how can you find the one you need
you could for example use the search
function on the sigmaaldrich.com web
page
after entering your search term you can
then refine your search results by
choosing the quality grade or the format
of your need
on the left hand column
another possibility is to browse our
product categories on the reference
materials main
page sigmaaldrich.com standards
a tip here when you click on one of
these categories
and then on one of the subcategories you
can again refine your choice
by defining quality grade or formats
to make it even more easy for you we
also set up some segment specific pages
for food pharma and environmental
testing
here you will quickly find the relevant
product groups and subpages
for the corresponding testing segments
let's have a look at the food segment
page
the most relevant product categories are
here organized
in nine tiles the first group is
representing our microbiology crms
this range consists of more than 100
hydro-soluble disks
with certified cfu levels for the most
common bacteria and microorganisms
under the brands vitroids and lenticules
the second group is pesticides where we
have a very comprehensive portfolio of
more than
1400 certified reference materials
reference materials and analytical
standards grade
the latter under the well-known
pesticide
biotoxins are including mycotoxins
marine toxins cyanotoxins or
alkaloids the portfolio of veterinary
drugs
includes antibiotics and hormones crms
and standards of the brand veterinal
the tab food identity testing
combines some niche product lines for
example dna standards for
animal and fish identity testing
botanical reference materials
or crms for genetically modified
organisms
other contaminants include heavy metals
packaging contaminants
and food dyes the remaining types
include physical properties food matrix
materials
and a type called food quality testing
that combines amino acids
lipids carbohydrates vitamins or
phytochemicals
we unfortunately don't have time now to
discuss all of these product groups in
detail
but i would like to highlight three
product groups of special interest
or where we have recently launched
exciting new products
three highlight topics are marine toxins
extractables and leachables or food
contact materials
and food matrix materials here it is
highlighted where you can find these on
the food segment page
marine toxins are mainly produced by
algae
but they can be very harmful to humans
when they accumulate
through the food chain these toxic algae
are growing exponentially in so-called
algae blooms
it is difficult to predict when and
where such
algae blooms occur furthermore
due to global warming these can also
spread now to areas
where they were previously unknown
the development of lcms to become
increasingly sensitive
is causing a shift from older biological
assays
to lcms to test these toxins
therefore reliable reference materials
are required
but there is a challenge for us
reference materials producers
the pure toxins have to be isolated from
algae
and are mostly only available in very
small quantities
so we are using a combined method of
quantitative nmr
and isotope dilution ms to certify these
compounds
we call micro qnmr
a few milligram are enough to prepare a
stock solution
analog code of this solution is
quantified by
quantitative nmr after that the stock
solution is diluted to the final
concentration of the crm
and filled in ampoules the stability
tests are then performed
by isotope dilution ms
using this method we have so far
launched 15 crm solutions
for example the native form but also an
isotope labeled crm of saxitoxin
hydrochloride
as a representative of the paralytic
shellfish toxins
or the more recently added orcadic acid
or groups like brevitoxins and pinot
toxins
i am showing only some examples of
different product groups here to
demonstrate the variety of chemical
structures these toxins have
the next highlight group are our
reference materials for extractables and
leachables
or for food contact materials
the term extractables and leachables is
mainly in use in the context of
pharmaceutical products and medical
devices
in the field of food the more common
term used is food
contact materials there are many
region or country specific regulations
for food contact materials these often
define
what chemicals are allowed to be used to
produce materials that come into contact
with food
they usually come with a positive list
of chemicals
but also defining maximum migration
limits for a lot of these
in addition also the occurrence or
formation
of non-unintentionally added substances
has to be controlled
so extractables and leachables and food
contact materials
do have a different regulatory
background
but a lot of the target analytes are
widely overlapping
still we are facing thousands of
potential contaminants
this means that the analysis is usually
not target specific
a big challenge is that no potential
contaminant
should be overlooked in the analysis
while there are thousands of potential
analytes
with very different structures
so for a reference material mix we would
like a broad range of analytes with
different physical chemical properties
to make sure that the analytical method
used is suitable to find a wide range of
chemical structures
also we wanted to focus on the most
commonly found
extractables and on the most toxic ones
to develop these products our internal
colleagues from the extractables and
leachables slab
from the central analytical services in
darmstadt
helped us to define the most useful
combination of analytes
for reference materials they would also
use internally
based on this collaboration we launched
two first screening mixes for
extractables and legibles
one with chemicals typical for lc and
another one for gc
extractable studies you can find these
products
under the url given here
the last product group i would like to
focus on is food matrix
materials these are real life samples of
different matrices
certified for the content of certain
analytes
such as mycotoxins in vine or heavy
metals in milk powder
or there are countless combinations
actually
materials can be used to develop or
validate analytical methods
including the sample preparation step to
correct for matrix effects
to make it easier to find a suitable
product among the more than 200 food
matrix reference materials in our
offering
on our web page you will find the
products listed by
analyte type or by matrix type
so if for example you are interested in
materials for fish
and seafood you can easily find all the
related matrix materials
that are available one very interesting
new addition
is a range of food matrix materials
certified for
elemental content of carbon nitrogen
hydrogen and sulfur
or for isotope ratio
these products are very well suited to
verify your results
in elemental analysis or isotope ratio
in food matrices to potentially detect
food fraud or adulteration
we are planning to further expand our
offering for food matrix materials
and offer a bigger variety of matrix
analyte combinations
for this we would appreciate the input
from our customers
so we can be focusing on the products
that are most needed by you
so if you could take five to ten minutes
and fill out a little survey on our
webpage
this would be very helpful for us thanks
a lot
i have been talking now all the time
just about reference materials
since this is of course the topic of
this webinar
but at last i also would like to point
out that our company is offering all
consumables
that you will need in your analytical
workflow under the sopelko brand
from sample preparation products like
spe
over to solvents analytical reagents
tlc plates or chromatographic columns
if you would like to be kept up to date
about new product additions
regulations or a lot of useful
applications
i would like to recommend you to
subscribe to our analytics reporter
magazine
which is issued about four times a year
and you can get either printed or also
as an online version by email
so please visit our webpage at
sigmaaldrich.com
analytics to subscribe
with that i have reached the end of my
presentation
i would like to say a big thank you to
the organizers of this event
and of course i thank you all for your
interest and your attention
thank you very much
and thank you dr knowledge for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
remember if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask the question box
located at the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
have some incoming
questions already from our audience
members
dr knold which is the better
certification
method quantitative nmr
or mass balance
yeah that's uh not such an easy question
to answer
i i would actually consider both to be
equivalent in terms of of a current
accuracy and traceability of the results
of course
both of these methods have their
advantages and maybe disadvantages
for example what i like particularly
about qnmr is that
the compound of interest is directly
tested
well it's indirectly
for the mass balance on the other hand
mass balance also provides
a full panorama full view of the whole
material
including all the impurities so i
couldn't say which one
is better we are using both of these
both methods
are are also really
valid methods
thank you dr knowles and you mentioned
that you are working on expanding the
offering for food matrix materials are
there any new product launches planned
soon
yeah actually we have quite a big
pipeline for
new products for food matrix material we
are collaborating with
uh ferra papas in in the uk
and we are about to launch 41 new uh
products for various
[Music]
matrices and analytes from from them
and then we have another 37 new products
in pipeline that should be launched soon
that are
manufactured by the company trilogy and
these are mainly
mycotoxins in various different matrices
and then we also have some projects to
develop internal
internally matrix materials in
collaboration with uh
this metrological institute yeah so
yeah so you see that a lot is going on
and you are going to see
this portfolio growing over the next few
months
wonderful thank you and again thank you
audience members for your questions
today
we have one more question are you
offering all the three quality
grades crm rm
and analytical standard for any given
analyte
um no that that would not be actually
feasible so
it really depends of course if
there are so many potential analyze of
course for an analyze which is
very important very often used like for
example ascorbic acid
you will find different quality levels
available
but for more let's say niche compounds
that are not so often tested usually
it's not economically
feasible to to do the certification to
crm
so then there's only an analytical
standards grade
available but also there might be other
examples like the
marine toxins where the material is very
expensive the starting material
so actually the cost difference isn't
even
so high between an analytical standard
and the crm grade
so there it wouldn't make sense to offer
an analytical standard and you only have
the crm
so you can see it really it really
depends
on on which compound it is
but we we cannot offer all the quality
grades for all
for all the products
dr noel thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via
contact information
you provide at the time of registration
and i also want to thank our sponsor
millapor sigma
for today's webinar this webcast can be
viewed on demand through june of 2021
until next time take care be safe
bye-bye now
you